[Music]  i'm chris wallace and i have been at fox  news for 18 years  personally it has been the job of a  lifetime i  have been in this business for 50 years  and i can truthfully say the last 18  have been the best years of my career  why is it that so many of the people  that oppose vladimir putin  end up dead  my proudest moment at fox was when i got  to moderate a presidential debate  secretary of state hillary clinton and  donald j trump that was a tremendous  moment there was a real question back in  1996 whether fox news would still be  around and here we are 25 years later  it is a permanent part of the american  media landscape  it has been  a great ride  you